[Music]
you tweeted a picture today that I
wanted to show a brand new to Twitter
everybody okay well this is you're
trying to figure it out okay no yeah
okay your your children are adorable
beautiful children eventually what my I
went to now I'm hoping or trusting that
that's Jerry in the background and not
me it might be glad Amir Putin yeah okay
well let's check this out what why is
this is that underwear or is it my
husband Jerry O'Connell is a guy who
wears a speedo hold on a very regular
basis hold on I heard very few Woo's no
no no no I heard it I have heard and
women have said one thing over the years
time and time again they say you know
what they like the boxer brief thing but
they don't like a guy in speedos
I listen we both have European dads we
all know European men are notorious
speedo wearers smugglers yeah Jerry's a
swimmer he's an avid swimmer he's
considerate of other people's feelings
he realizes that some people aren't
comfortable around that so he will like
put on some baggy shorts if he knows
people are gonna be uncomfortable but
when it's just us yeah he's a guy who
wears a speedo did you ever know that I
like the way it looks
I like he's he's a very long lean
swimmer type body it looks great in a
suit he's not all muscled out he's uh
you don't like a guy with muscles I like
a guy who's long and lean yeah you like
a long lean guy
you got muscles
I'm right here I was here I was here
long before you met Jerry and we had a
real connection
and now I find out that I am your ideal
body type it is magic I mean I feel the
sparks every time I'm around you true
actually might be an electrical problem
the wiring here is really bad okay but
you don't mind a speedo because I'm
shocked at how many times I've heard
women say yes feetoes oh if a guy wears
a speedo I'm gone you know they just
don't like it it's like too much
information for the woman there is I
can't
whether whatever my opinion is doesn't
matter he's gonna wear a speedo anyway
that's just who you this year but I do
like it yeah but he doesn't wear the
thong speedo no he doesn't wear a thong
is PETA okay okay okay
not yet I heard I actually heard some
disappointment out there that guy
sounded really disappointed oh there he
is
lebombo
[Music]
you have a new TNT show it's called King
and Maxwell Maxwell you don't have
noticed about TNT they love two names
Rizzoli Isles Franklin bash King Maxwell
King and Maxwell TNT knows drama and TNT
knows ampersands nice maybe a Europe
maybe sometime in the future romaine
O'Brien maybe let's could we could do a
show together there's an undeniable
chemistry
you got it let's do it okay okay I'm
ready I hear no one responding that was
the sound of America saying actually you
heard wheels die they're trying to
picture what the show would be yeah
beautiful you and then I come in in a
leprechaun speedo tell us about the show
King and Maxwell disgraced private
investigator a Secret Service people
turned private investigators so we work
you used to work with the Secret Service
now we are private investigators we work
in DC and it's the you know very
handsome talented John Tenney and myself
and Monday nights on TNT it's a great
show we love it we have a clip here
anything we need to know for this clip I
believe the clip we have is the two of
us chasing down a perp who is stolen a
cell phone all right
Horton's cell phone let's take a look at
this clip from King and Maxwell
[Music]
give me the phone screw you okay you
don't have to break my wrist police
brutality except for we're not cops
which puts us in a unique position
Rachel let me go
don't do what my partner just said is
that being private investigators we're
able to make you an offer
Dax Walters to two to one Washington
Court apartment 303 what kind of mother
names her kid - it was a good
[Applause]